hi Shanti Shanti yeah I heard your name
- they were saying it - names what do
you mean trying to like Shawn it had to
be so nice to meet you nice to meet you
a huge will in grace man thank you I
have to say so look behind us I know I
always I walked in here and was just
like is this real life
in that well yeah 20 years ago I was 10
years old really yeah I mean - grace
what school did you go to I don't think
I'm no no I mean I'm Canadian so the
last time in there and there in your
heart the last time we saw Jack he was
getting a marriage proposal
yes will we see your character plan a
wedding this season yes so Jack and a
Stefan his name is a stefan gloria
anybody beautiful stefan Gloria do you
get that I oh I got it okay so Jack and
I Stefan are getting married and this
this season is all about planning the
wedding now where it ends up I don't
know yet the writers haven't told me but
so it could go one of two ways it could
go you know happy ending you know sail
off into the sunset or it could have
complications and who knows how that
goes but both our ripe or ripe with
stories what is it ripe ripe right so
they would just say full of stories full
right um so Jack do you think that he
would be a groomzilla that's funny
probably a touch of that probably
touching yeah yeah I step on it probably
a little bit be a little more together
yes okay
I can't imagine Jack just being married
period it's just not the way that I
imagined them right right which I kind
of like because maybe that's something
we haven't seen yet yeah what kind of
husband do you think Jack would be
I think he probably don't know
I am jacket probably be not too
different yeah you know and probably
have a wandering eye oh right
because that's just kind of who he is
but yeah we'll have to see yes
so Will and Grace you guys always talk
about world issues and there's so much
going on right now is there any you know
topical storylines that we can expect
you guys to talk about this season you
know the great thing about the show is
the characters on the show are going
through the same things that the country
and the world is going through so it's
very self-aware in that way so the the
show's always fall under the umbrella of
kind of relevance right so whatever is
relevant at the moment pop culture sex
religion politics anything so it's it's
all off the table as they say on the
table so I mean we can talk about any of
it at any time so and they're great
about being self-aware enough about and
the comedic timing between you and Meg
megan is my favorite some of the best on
network television
um what is it like working with her
because she's just a joy to be around
Megan is like ultimate professional
knows all her lines immediately in
action she goes into character and it's
always such a good time you know she's
always always always nails it you never
never a bad take never bad take what can
the fans expect for this season anything
exciting particularly that you can tell
us well we have a really fun exciting
guest star on the show and his name is
David Schwimmer from the television
friends and so his character's name is
Noah and Noah and grace are a new love
interest and David will be doing many
episodes so that's kind of a nice little
added color to complicate things yes
third season getting picked up
congratulations thank you did you
imagine that there would be diehard fans
just having such an appetite for Will
and Grace no I mean I mean going back to
2016 when we made that election video
yeah I'm still waiting to hear so the
response of that has been so huge that
we were we did that for no result other
than to send the message out to vote yes
we were not looking for anything from it
but here we are so and that's just the
Testaments and the fans and that's why
we're doing it and so many amazing guest
stars is there anybody on your wish list
anyone that hasn't been on the show yet
that's in your heart I would say to
people I see Meryl Streep because I
think they'll be really interesting in
Dwayne Johnson because it would be so
unexpected like your mother and your
father
oh yeah Meryl Streep and Dwayne Johnson
- Larry yeah and nobody questions the
oddity of that yes no I would love it
thank you thank you so much we're
excited about the new season thank you
Mike yes thank you you're so sweet